TWO MEN ARE FACING CHARGES AFTER
ONE OF THEM TRIED TO STEAL AN
AIRPORT TRANSPORT CARD FROM
EMPLOYEE.
AND NOW THERE IS A PUSHING
CONGRESS TO BAN BOOZE ON
AIRPLANES.
GREG, LET ME GO TO EUCHARIST.
THIS CLEARLY IS AN ISSUE FOR
FLIGHT ATTENDANTS AND FOUR
PASSENGERS.
BUT IS BANNING BOOZE THE ANSWER
TO THIS CHALLENGE AND PROBLEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY NO.
STOP BLAMING BOOZE FOR THE
ACTIONS OF A FEW BAD EGGS.
WE HAD TO ADMIT THAT WE ARE IN A
TIME OF PEAK STRESS.
EVERYONE FROM THE PILOTS TO
FLIGHT ATTENDANTS TO JESSE IN
44B, EVERYONE HAS MAY BE
PERSONAL ISSUE AT HOME, THAT IS
ONE LAYER.
THAT IS ONE LAYER.
THEY NEED TO TACK ON THE
ARTIFICIAL PRESSURES OF THE
HOLIDAYS.
THAT IS A SECOND LAYER.
THEN YOU AND COVID, THAT IS A
THIRD LAYER.
YOU TAKE AWAY BOOZE?
THAT IS A FOURTH LAYER OF
HEAVY-DUTY STRESS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT HUMANS ARE
BUNDLES OF STRESS.
WE NEED TO TREAD LIGHTLY AND
POLITELY.
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL OUT THAT HE
GOT A NICE LITTLE CARD FROM
DELTA IN THE MAIL THAT THANKED
ME FOR MY SERVICE WORK FOR USING
THEM.
I EXPECTED SOMETHING OTHER THAN
A THANK YOU, BUT THAT IS OKAY.
BUT I FLY OUT TO MAUER ON
AMERICAN AIRLINES.
I EXPECT GREAT SERVICE BY GREAT
PEOPLE.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE I WILL NOT BE
REPRIMANDED AT MY MASK SLIPS.
I WILL BE ENJOYING A FEW
LIBATIONS WHILE LISTENING TO MY
FAVORITE MUSIC AND EVERYTHING IS
GOING TO BE GREAT.
FLYING IN AMERICA.
>> JESSE, YOUR NAME WAS IN BOTH.
HATTIE REG REACTED THIS?
>> IVAN SAT IN THE 40s SINCE
MY 20s.
GET A RIDE, GUTFELD.
BUT YOU CAN'T TAKE AWAY ALCOHOL
ON A PLANE.
YOU HAVE YOUR SHOWER BEER, YOU
HAVE YOUR SKI LIFT CHAIR BEER,
YOU HAVE YOUR YACHT COCKTAIL,
AND YOU HAVE YOUR AIRLINE DRINK.
AND PLUS, IT IS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
DRINK ALCOHOL ON A FLIGHT TO
RELAX THEIR NERVES.
SO DON'T MESS WITH MEDICINE, I
WOULD SAY.
THE OTHER THING IS, PEOPLE WOULD
STOP BALLING IF THEY DRESS
BETTER.
REMEMBER HOW PEOPLE USED TO
DRESSED ON THE AIRLINES?
LIKE THREES PIECE SUITS AND
DRESSES PRE AND EVERYONE IS
SUITS.
YEAH, YOU'RE GOING TO RUMBLE IN
A SWEAT SUIT BUT IF YOU LOOK
REALLY SYMBOLIZE YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO -- SO JUST DRESS NICELY
AND JUST KEEP CALM.
>> DANA, YOU STRIKE ME AS
SOMEONE WHO DOES A LOT OF WHAT
JESSE WAS SAYING THERE.
DO YOU THINK THAT BANNING BOOZE
IS THE RIGHT THING?
>> I WAS IN TURN TERMS OF
BRAWLING OR THE DRESSING NICELY.
>> NO, NO, AND DRESSING NICELY
AND BEING POLITE.
>> I'M TIRED OF BEING PUNISHED
AND THINGS TAKEN AWAY FROM ME
BECAUSE A FEW PEOPLE CAN'T
HANDLE THINGS WELL.
THERE IS AN IDEA THAT WAS
FLOATED THAT IF YOU GET INTO ONE
OF THESE BRAWLS AT THE AIRPORT,
YOU COULD BE BANNED FROM TSA
PRETAX.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO BE BANNED
FROM TSA PRECHECKS.
THEY TAKE AWAY BOOZE, PEOPLE
WOULD TAKE PILLS.
I NEVER DID BUT I MIGHT BE
TEMPTED.
>> SEE ME AFTER THE SHOW.
>> DRINKING AT THE AIRPORT AND
ON PLANES IS NOT NEW.
PEOPLE ARE DRINKING TOO MUCH
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO DO WITHOUT A
MASK ON.
SO YOU TAKE AWAY THE MASKS, ALL
THE CEOs HAVE SAID, IT DOESN'T
DO ANYTHING ON THE PLANE.
DR. FAUCI WANTS YOU TO WEAR A
MASK FOREVER.
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LISTED
THE MANDATES I GUARANTEE YOU
PEOPLE GO BACK TO BEHAVING
THEMSELVES IN DRINKING BECAUSE
IT'S THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO
IN THE AIRPORT WITHOUT HAVING
YOUR MASK ON.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH YOU CAN